Since the beginning of the war in Gaza, Yousef Hammash has been a master of good timing and good luck. We did a story about him a few months ago. Let me remind you for a minute who he is and how capably he got his family from place to place.
自加沙战争开始以来，尤瑟夫·哈马什（Yousef Hammash）一直是个懂得把握时机且运气不错的人。几个月前我们报道过他的故事。让我先花一分钟带大家回顾一下他是谁，以及他有多么能干，把一家人从一个地方转移到另一个地方。
Hamas attacked Israel on October 7. Yousef fled his home on October 8 because he was afraid that Jabalia, where he was from, was going to be bombed. And the next day, October 9, Jabalia was bombed. As the war moved, he moved a second time, down south, to a city called Khan Younis. Then Israel dropped leaflets from the sky telling everybody to evacuate Khan Younis immediately and get to safety further south in Rafah.
哈马斯于10月7日袭击了以色列。尤瑟夫在10月8日逃离了家园，因为他担心自己居住的贾巴利亚（Jabalia）会遭到轰炸。果然第二天，10月9日，贾巴利亚就遭到了轰炸。随着战事推进，他第二次转移，前往南部的汗尤尼斯市（Khan Younis）。随后，以色列从空中投下传单，要求所有人立即撤离汗尤尼斯，前往更南端的拉法（Rafah）避难。
Yousef packed up the car that day, his wife Manal, his kids, his mom, and made his third move. And this is around the time that he started having conversations with one of our producers here, Chana Joffe-Walt. He told Chana that he knew his sisters, who were in Khan Younis, needed also to go to Rafah. And he kept wheedling, arguing, pleading, making promises, wearing them down.
尤瑟夫当天就收拾好车子，带着妻子马纳尔（Manal）、孩子们和母亲，进行了第三次搬迁。大约就在那时，他开始与我们的制作人查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）交谈。他告诉查娜，他知道此时身在汗尤尼斯的姐妹们也必须去拉法。他不断地劝说、争辩、恳求、许诺，磨破了嘴皮子。
And they still did not move until an airstrike hit the building next to them. Terrifying, right? Yousef raced to where they were, and as soon as they saw each other, Yousef and his sister shared their relief by being exactly how they always are with each other.
然而，直到一枚空袭炸弹击中了她们隔壁的建筑，她们才肯搬走。太可怕了，对吧？尤瑟夫飞奔到她们那里，两人一见面，尤瑟夫和他的姐妹们就像往常一样，用他们特有的方式表达了劫后余生的庆幸。
The first thing I said today when I met them-- there is no discussion. We are leaving.
我今天见到她们时说的第一句话就是——没得商量。我们走。
So you didn't hug them and cry and say, I'm so glad you survived. You said, get in the car.
所以你没有拥抱她们，没有哭泣，没有说“真高兴你们还活着”。你说的是，“上车”。
No, no, we have a different type of relation. It's not about hugging them. I was laughing. You should have died. [LAUGHS] I should be in the morgue now. [LAUGHS] This is how I am with my sisters.
不，不，我们的关系比较特殊。这不是拥抱那一套。我在笑。你应该死掉的。[笑声] 我现在应该在太平间才对。[笑声] 这就是我和姐妹们相处的方式。
And did they laugh? What did they say to that?
她们笑了吗？她们是怎么回应的？
Eh, Hadil was like, ah, you know. Actually, they will start to give me orders quickly. You need to talk to our cousin Emani because he was hosting us. You need to invite him. Also, go to our Uncle Eena because they wanted--
呃，哈迪尔（Hadil）说，啊，你知道的。其实，她们很快就开始对我发号施令了。你需要和我们的表兄埃马尼（Emani）谈谈，因为是他收留了我们。你需要邀请他。还有，去找我们的叔叔伊纳（Uncle Eena），因为她们想——
Finally, he took his sisters to safety in Rafah in a tent camp that he built for them. This was back in December. Over time, Yousef's tent camp of extended family in Rafah grew to 60 people, with Yousef managing it as mayor, repairman, caterer, driver, health care provider.
最后，他把姐妹们带到了拉法，住进了他为她们搭建的帐篷营地。那是去年12月的事了。随着时间的推移，尤瑟夫在拉法的大家庭帐篷营地人数增加到了60人，尤瑟夫身兼数职：市长、维修工、餐饮经理、司机和医疗保健提供者。
And then, on the same day Yousef's sister Aseel had a baby, bringing the population of the tent camp to 61, the prime minister of Israel announced he was planning to evacuate Rafah and invade the city where Yousef's family and over a million other Palestinians were living.
就在尤瑟夫的姐妹阿西尔（Aseel）生下孩子，使帐篷营地人口达到61人的那天，以色列总理宣布他计划撤离拉法，并对尤瑟夫一家及其他一百多万巴勒斯坦人居住的城市发起进攻。
Yousef was facing moving everybody for a fourth time. And he's always been the one who's made this call for his family. Yousef's the one who decides. It's too dangerous to stay where we are. And this is when we have to go. It has to be now. And this is where we're going next. But this time, Yousef didn't know where to go next to keep everybody safe and together. They got as far south as you can go in Gaza. There really might not be another place to run to. He told Chana back then--
尤瑟夫面临着第四次举家搬迁。他一直都是家族中做决策的人。尤瑟夫说了算。待在原地太危险了。我们必须现在离开。这就是我们要去的下一个地方。但这一次，尤瑟夫不知道该去哪里才能保证大家的安全和团聚。他们已经到了加沙的最南端。这里可能真的没有其他地方可以逃去了。当时他告诉查娜——
I feel, to be honest, I don't want to think about that because I know there is no solution. And unfortunately, this time, I'm completely useless because I ran out of options. So what am I going to do?
老实说，我不想去想这个问题，因为我知道根本没有解决办法。不幸的是，这一次，我彻底没辙了，因为我已无路可走。那我该怎么办？
I have never heard you talk like that, Yousef. I've never heard you say that. You're always the guy that's like, yeah, I'll figure it out. I'll call so-and-so tomorrow, or no, we don't have it right now, but I'll figure it out.
尤瑟夫，我从未听你这样说过。我从未听你这么讲。你总是那个说“好吧，我会解决的。我明天给某某打电话，或者不，我们现在没有这个，但我会想办法”的人。
I don't have options ahead of me. When I have options, I'll start to think deeply about it. But up to now, I'm completely useless.
我面前已经没有选择了。当我有选择时，我会深入思考。但到现在为止，我彻底没辙了。
But there was one other option. It was just one that Yousef had never seriously considered. They could try to leave Gaza, which might seem like an obvious choice that anybody would want to do-- flee the place where bombs are falling, and it's getting harder and harder to find food and drinkable water. But it's not an obvious choice for Yousef and for lots of people, as you'll hear.
但还有最后一个选择。只是尤瑟夫从未认真考虑过。他们可以尝试离开加沙，这对任何人来说似乎都是显而易见的明智之举——逃离炸弹横飞、食物和饮用水越来越难找的地方。但对于尤瑟夫和许多人来说，这并不是一个显而易见的选择，正如你们接下来将听到的那样。
Today, what happens when Yousef gets pressed into a fourth move, one that he has deeply mixed feelings about and is not even sure he can pull off. And that's to try to get his family out as quickly as possible before Israel invades the city where they're living. Time, he knew, was not on his side.
今天，当尤瑟夫被迫进行第四次转移时会发生什么？他对此心情复杂，甚至不确定自己能否做到。那就是在以色列进攻他们居住的城市之前，尽快带家人逃离。他知道，时间对他不利。
And if you think you can imagine what that entails, let me tell you, you really do not know the half of it. You're about to witness feats of ingenuity, strokes of luck, and big piles of cash on a deadline against enormous odds. And also, you'll see how hard it is on this family to make this decision, how even trying to go tears them up, tears Yousef up. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And with that, I'll turn things over to Chana.
如果你认为你能想象这意味着什么，那我告诉你，你连一半都不了解。你即将见证在巨大压力下，人们展现出的聪明才智、一线生机以及巨额现金的运作。你还会看到这个家庭在做这个决定时有多么痛苦，哪怕只是尝试离开，都会让他们心碎，让尤瑟夫崩溃。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。现在，把时间交给查娜。
Yousef did not want to leave Gaza, where he's from, a place where he knows everyone, knows every system, has connections everywhere. His job is doing humanitarian work in Gaza for Gazans, and his entire family is in Gaza. A core part of Yousef's identity is that he takes care of the family. So Yousef had no plan to leave, did not even want to think about leaving Gaza. And then, one day in February, he found out he might leave Gaza. He was in the car with his wife, Manal, and their kids.
尤瑟夫不想离开加沙，那是他的家乡，是一个他认识所有人、熟悉每一套运作机制、四处都有人脉的地方。他的工作是在加沙为加沙人从事人道主义工作，他的整个家庭也都在加沙。照顾家庭是尤瑟夫核心身份的一部分。所以尤瑟夫根本没计划离开，甚至不想考虑离开加沙。然后，二月份的一天，他发现自己可能得离开加沙了。当时他和妻子马纳尔以及孩子们在车里。
I was going with Manal to her parents. We were visiting her parents. And I had my daughter, Illya, five years old Illya, telling me that we are going to travel to Egypt.
我要带马纳尔去她父母家。我们当时正在探望她的父母。我的女儿伊利亚（Illya），五岁，告诉我我们要去埃及旅行。
That meant to you they're talking about it during the day, and she's overhearing it?
这是否意味着他们在白天谈论这件事，而她无意中听到了？
Yes. So I understood that when my daughter came to ask me, it means that they reached the limit of how much they want to do it.
是的。所以我明白，当女儿来问我时，意味着他们想离开的念头已经到了极限。
Yousef did not realize that a conversation had started among the women in his family that wasn't so much happening behind his back as just away from him, in the places he wasn't.
尤瑟夫没意识到，他家族中的女性之间已经开始了一场谈话，与其说是背着他进行的，不如说是发生在他不在的场合。
Hi, Manal.
嗨，马纳尔。
Hi.
嗨。
Manal, I've heard so much about you.
马纳尔，我听说了很多关于你的事。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Me, too, my dear. I've heard a lot about you.
我也一样，亲爱的。我听说了很多关于你的事。
Manal says Yousef had told her and his mother he didn't want to leave. But if they ever wanted to leave Gaza, he would make it happen. And Manal and his mom said no. Their whole family's in Gaza.
马纳尔说尤瑟夫曾告诉她和他的母亲，他不想离开。但如果她们一定要离开加沙，他会设法办到。但马纳尔和母亲拒绝了。她们整个家族都在加沙。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
We felt it was wrong to travel and leave them behind.
我们觉得离开并抛下他们是不对的。
And Manal knew, like everyone thinking about leaving Gaza knows, if she left, there was a good possibility she'd never come back. So, no. She said she didn't want to leave, and she meant it. But then Manal thought, maybe? The idea stuck to her.
马纳尔像每一个考虑离开加沙的人一样清楚，如果她离开了，很有可能就再也回不来了。所以，不。她说她不想离开，她是真心的。但后来马纳尔心想，也许呢？这个想法挥之不去。
She thought of it when her children screamed through bombing or when they begged for chicken, instead of more canned food, when she noticed Illya had forgotten all of her alphabet. And she thought of it when she spent the entire day looking for wood to boil water so her kids could drink.
每当孩子们在轰炸声中尖叫，每当他们乞求吃鸡肉而不是更多罐头食品时，她就会想起这个念头。当她发现伊利亚已经忘记了所有的字母表时，她也想到了。当她花整整一天时间寻找木柴烧水给孩子们喝时，她也想到了。
She worried. What if they ran out of time? What if the Israelis showed up before Yousef had another plan? Then Manal mentioned all of this to one of Yousef's sisters, Aseel. Aseel is the sister who is most like Yousef-- decisive, a problem-solver, a planner.
她很担心。如果时间不够了怎么办？如果以色列人在尤瑟夫想出新计划前就打过来怎么办？于是马纳尔把这一切告诉了尤瑟夫的姐妹阿西尔。阿西尔是尤瑟夫最像的姐妹——果断、善于解决问题、有计划性。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I went to Aseel. She was the first to encourage me. She said, let the children live a good life. Go, leave. She encouraged me. Honestly, Aseel is the closest to me because she's been my friend since childhood. I consider her like a sister, my favorite friend and the best friend I have.
我去找了阿西尔。她是第一个鼓励我的人。她说，让孩子们过上好生活吧。走吧，离开这里。她鼓励了我。老实说，阿西尔是我最亲近的人，因为她从小就是我的朋友。我把她当作姐妹，我最好的朋友。
For her to encourage me to do it, that was very good for me because she knew what my interests were and told me my best interest was in leaving Gaza. I thought we should harden our hearts a bit and leave for the sake of our children.
她能鼓励我这样做对我意义重大，因为她了解我的利益所在，并告诉我离开加沙最符合我的利益。我心想，我们应该狠下心，为了孩子离开这里。
The process of considering leaving Gaza in this war is not just one of weighing options, one item after another. It's also getting people's blessings. It's a series of permissions. There was Aseel-- gave her blessing. Eventually, the other sisters did, too, knowing that they were not going to go, couldn't go. They had their own extended families and lives in Gaza.
在战争中考虑离开加沙的过程，不仅仅是权衡利弊，更是一个获得他人祝福和许可的过程。阿西尔给了她祝福。最终，其他姐妹也同意了，尽管她们知道自己不会走，也走不了。她们有自己的大家庭和在加沙的生活。
Yousef's mom, after some persuading, agreed to go with Manal and Yousef and the kids. So it was decided. Manal told her kids they were going. And for her, that was the happiest moment, the relief of being able to say to her kids, this will end for you. They were excited, so excited that Illya, the five-year-old, ended up breaking the news to her dad in the car before Manal even had a chance to tell him.
尤瑟夫的母亲在经过一番劝说后，同意和马纳尔、尤瑟夫及孩子们一起走。决定就这样做出了。马纳尔告诉孩子们他们要走了。对她来说，那是她最开心的时刻，那种能够告诉孩子们“这一切对你们来说将要结束”的释然。孩子们很兴奋，兴奋到五岁的伊利亚在车里直接把消息告诉了爸爸，马纳尔甚至还没来得及说。
So you're thinking about leaving when? Soon? And how?
那你打算什么时候走？很快吗？打算怎么走？
First of all, it's very, very expensive. Very expensive. It's a very long process-- unclear process, actually. You know, there is a lot of playing here and there. I try to not ignore it, postpone it. Unfortunately, when I think about the decision itself, I get lost quickly because there is loads of details behind that decision. Ah, it's really difficult. But making that decision is not getting along with my personality.
首先，这非常、非常昂贵。非常贵。这是一个非常漫长的过程——实际上是不透明的过程。你知道，中间有很多猫腻。我试着不去理会，想拖延一下。不幸的是，当我想到这个决定本身时，我很快就迷失了，因为这个决定背后有太多的细节。啊，真的很难。但做这个决定与我的个性不符。
It's not getting along with your personality?
这与你的个性不符？
Yes, 160 days of war, and that wasn't enough to raise the idea in my head that I should leave Gaza. Leaving now, it's kind of, I am escaping my responsibility towards my sisters, my responsibility toward my job, my responsibility towards my friends who I'm supporting. But I'm standing ahead my responsibility towards my children. It's very-- I don't know. It's very difficult decision if you put these two responsibilities in front of you, and you have to choose.
是的，160天的战争，还不足以让我在脑海中升起“我应该离开加沙”的念头。现在离开，某种程度上就像是在逃避我对姐妹们的责任、对工作的责任，以及对我正在支持的朋友们的责任。但我现在面前摆着的是我对孩子们的责任。这非常……我不知道。如果把这两项责任放在一起让你选择，是非常困难的。
This was March. Israel continued to say, our plan is to invade Rafah. Yousef knew, if they did invade, they might close the border. There was limited time to act. He agreed it was the right choice for his children.
那是三月份。以色列继续宣称，我们的计划是入侵拉法。尤瑟夫知道，如果他们真的入侵，可能会关闭边境。采取行动的时间所剩无几。他同意这对他的孩子来说是正确的选择。
And yet, everything about how this move was happening was different, slower than I'd seen Yousef act through the entire war-- not that he was stalling. He'd made some calls. He was going through the steps. But old Yousef would have made 1,000 calls, checking all the angles, calling in favors, urgently reading everything available about what Israel might do next and when. And now, this Yousef did not sound like a person who knows there may only be a small window to make your next move. And it's easy to be too late.
然而，这次搬迁过程中的一切都与众不同，比我在整个战争期间看到的尤瑟夫的行事节奏要慢得多——并不是他在拖延。他打了一些电话。他在按部就班地走程序。但如果是以前的尤瑟夫，他会打1000个电话，查清所有角度，动用各种人情关系，紧急研读所有关于以色列下一步行动及其时间的可用信息。而现在的这个尤瑟夫，听起来不像是一个明白机会转瞬即逝、稍有不慎就会错失的人。
But for me, to be honest, I am not thinking about it deeply. And I'm very sorry. And I know it's a wrong way, but for me, the only thing that I can do is to keep avoiding thinking about it until it became more closer.
但老实说，我没有深入去想。我很抱歉。我知道这种处理方式不对，但对我来说，我唯一能做的就是逃避思考它，直到它迫在眉睫。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
I will do it. I'm starting the process and all of that. Yeah, it's very long process, very complicated process.
我会去做的。我正在启动这个程序之类的。是的，这是一个非常漫长的过程，非常复杂。
Yousef couldn't talk about the process, how they'd get out on the record. He worried, justifiably, that any public statement could jeopardize their chances of getting out. What he could say was that he had paid to register his family to leave, and that at some point, his family's names would appear on a list of people allowed to cross the Rafah border. But when that would happen-- unclear.
尤瑟夫不能在公开场合谈论这个过程，也不能说他们是如何离开的。他有充分的理由担心，任何公开声明都可能危及他们离开的机会。他能说的是，他已经付钱注册了让家人离开，在某个时候，他家人的名字会出现在获准穿过拉法边境的名单上。但那是什么时候——还不清楚。
Another week passed, then another. Those blessings Manal had collected from everyone in the family, they meant it, but the longer this wait went on, the blessings got a little worn. Yousef started seeing it when he checked in on his sisters.
又过了一周，又是一周。马纳尔从家里所有人那里收集到的祝福，他们是真心的，但随着等待时间的延长，这些祝福变得有些褪色了。尤瑟夫在探望姐妹们时开始感觉到这一点。
One of the incidents happened. We had an issue between one of my sisters and her husband. And when I went there, I had to, yaani, solve the issue there. And I found out that my sisters were complaining. Yeah, so he's leaving. He's leaving us here in these circumstances. Blah, blah, blah. And they were a bit annoyed. So I was like, OK, now you were pushing for that. And now you are objecting that. Then I found out it's a moment that they were angry and all of that, and it's fine.
发生了一件事。我的一个姐妹和她丈夫之间出了点问题。当我去那里的时候，我不得不，就是说，解决那里的问题。我发现我的姐妹们在抱怨。是的，他要走了。他要把我们留在这里，在这种环境下。诸如此类。她们有点恼火。所以我当时说，好吧，之前是你们催着要走的。现在你们又反对了。后来我发现，那只是她们生气时的一时冲动，没事的。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
I know how they feel about it. And I know how they are scared. And I believe they have the right to be scared. It does feel me guilty. It makes me feel guilty. But I am already guilty from the beginning. So I already--
我了解她们的感受。我知道她们有多害怕。我相信她们有权利感到害怕。我确实感到内疚。这让我感到内疚。但从一开始我就已经感到内疚了。所以我已经——
You already feel guilty.
你已经感到内疚了。
Yeah, I really feel guilty.
是的，我真的感到内疚。
He was not doing his job keeping them safe and together. But while he waited, Yousef really did try on the safety front. He threw himself in to making sure his sisters would be OK without him there. He lined up a million backups-- a guy with a car in case they needed to leave quickly, a guy to help with broken phones, with internet problems.
他没能履行职责保护她们并让她们团聚。但在等待的过程中，尤瑟夫确实在安全方面做了努力。他倾尽全力确保姐妹们在他不在时也能平安无事。他安排了无数个备选方案——准备了一个有车的人以防她们需要紧急撤离，找了一个人帮忙维修损坏的手机，处理网络问题。
He told friends, I'm going to be calling on you. You need to look out for my sisters. He set up a contact at a currency shop so he could send money from Egypt. And he stashed emergency cash with several different people he trusted.
他告诉朋友们，我会找你们帮忙。你们要照看好我的姐妹们。他在一家货币兑换店建立了联系，以便能从埃及汇钱过去。他还把紧急现金存放在几个他信任的人那里。
Yeah, there is a lot of things had to be put in place and to be designated for someone, because I found out that I was doing a lot of things.
是的，有很多事情必须到位，并指定给某个人去办，因为我发现我一直在承担很多工作。
You have definitely been doing a lot of things. I would think you would need at least a dozen people to do all the jobs you've been doing.
你确实一直在做很多事。我想你至少需要十几个人才能完成你一直在做的所有工作。
I believe a hundred people would never do the job with love and passion, as I was doing it. It was always part of, give me energy, always, when I am managing things for them. That's the difference between me doing the job and a hundred people doing the job.
我相信一百个人也做不到像我这样带着爱和热情去完成这份工作。当我为她们打理这些事情时，这总是能给我能量。这就是我和一百个人做这项工作的区别。
President Biden was warning Israel not to invade Rafah. 26 EU countries issued a statement saying an invasion of Rafah would be catastrophic. Yousef continued to wait. There continued to be bombings, drones, gunfire all the time, but also something new that Yousef noticed happening around him in Rafah and at the family's tent camp-- a slow motion collapse.
拜登总统曾警告以色列不要入侵拉法。26个欧盟国家发表声明称，入侵拉法将是灾难性的。尤瑟夫继续等待。爆炸、无人机、枪声始终不断，但尤瑟夫还注意到拉法和帐篷营地周围发生了一些新的变化——一种缓慢的崩溃。
Every day, Yousef would notice a new deterioration of just daily life. There was no trash pickup, no police or services, nobody regulating traffic or businesses. There was no governance. One day, he'd get a call that someone's mother-in-law used the shower when it wasn't her family's day. And by the time Yousef arrived, the conflict had exploded for another day.
每一天，尤瑟夫都会发现日常生活又出现了新的恶化。没有垃圾清运，没有警察或公共服务，没有人管理交通或商业。没有了管理秩序。有一天，他接到电话，说有人趁不是自己家轮班的时候用了淋浴间。等尤瑟夫赶到时，冲突已经爆发了。
Yeah. [LAUGHS] So my brother-in-law had a fight with one of the neighbors. And my two brothers-in-law beating that guy and insult him in a bad way. And it happens that he's a friend of mine, and, ah, that was difficult. I had to intervene between both of them, apologizing here and there, trying to find the-- to mediate between them.
是的。[笑声] 我的姐夫和邻居打了一架。我的两个姐夫打了那个人还狠狠羞辱了他。恰好那个人还是我的朋友，这很难办。我不得不介入他们中间，到处道歉，试图找到……在他们之间进行调解。
What'd they fight about?
他们为什么打架？
Uh, small children had a fight. They went to speak with him. They didn't like the way he responded. It resulted in clashes by hand. Today, I have another one with one of the other brother-in-law with another neighbor for another stupid reason.
呃，小孩吵架了。他们去找那个人理论。他们不喜欢对方回应的方式。结果就动了手。今天，我的另一个姐夫又因为另一个愚蠢的原因和邻居打了一架。
The circumstances and what we are going through is pushing us to become unstable mentally. So everyone is under huge pressure from the amount of responsibilities that you have to do or just to move from a place to the other, just trying to get cash from a bank or an ATM. Everything is very dramatic.
现在的处境和我们所经历的一切正在把我们推向心理崩溃的边缘。每个人都承受着巨大的压力，无论是由于必须承担的任务，还是仅仅为了从一个地方搬到另一个地方，或者试图从银行或ATM机取点现金。一切都非常戏剧化。
The more of this Yousef saw, the more he settled in to the decision to go.
尤瑟夫看到的这些越多，他就越坚定了离开的决心。
Now it's really common. We see people with guns, a lot of disputes between families, a lot of killing crimes, looting. And that's affecting the entire society itself. People are fighting for no reasons now.
现在这很常见。我们看到有人持枪，家庭之间有很多争端，有很多谋杀犯罪，还有抢劫。这正在影响整个社会。人们现在无缘无故地争斗。
A few days ago, we had water trucking. So they had a lot of humanitarian organizations have provide water trucking where they send drinkable waters by trucks to these areas. We had a small dispute on the line where people put their jerry cans in line. Small disputes have resulted seven people killed, yaani. It's simple as that.
几天前，我们有运水车。许多人道主义组织提供水车，把饮用水送到这些地区。在排队放水桶的地方，我们发生了一点小争执。小争执导致了七个人死亡，就是这么简单。
What happened?
发生了什么？
I wasn't there, but I was hearing the shooting. It's next to us directly.
我不在现场，但我听到了枪声。就在我们旁边。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
It's like 100 meters away and a lot of ambulances. And what turned that fight is just a small line in front of drinking water. So that's one of the things that pushing me to-- no, I have to rescue my children from that.
离这里大约100米，来了很多救护车。导致那场打斗的仅仅是因为在饮用水前排队的一个小队列。所以这就是促使我——不，我必须把我的孩子们从那种环境中拯救出来。
But, Yousef, you've seen Israeli bombs destroy homes. You've seen much more dramatic than that. Why did that get to you?
但是，尤瑟夫，你见过以色列的炸弹摧毁房屋。你见过的场景比这戏剧性得多。为什么这件事对你触动这么大？
That's a good question. It feels different when you look to it as your own people. Then I don't justify for the Israelis what they are doing and what they are committing in Gaza. But with all the aggression that they are doing, it's a bit different, the way you see it, when you see it among your own people. But societies can easily be fragile and destroyed like our society is destroyed now.
这是个好问题。当你从自己人的角度去看待它时，感觉是不一样的。我并不认同以色列人在加沙所做的一切罪行。但面对他们所带来的所有侵略，当你看到自己人之间也变成这样时，你的看法会有些不同。社会很容易变得脆弱和崩溃，就像我们现在的社会一样。
Seven weeks after Israel announced plans to invade Rafah, Yousef and Manal were still waiting. Every night, they would check a Telegram channel called the Land Port Rafah Crossing.
在以色列宣布计划入侵拉法七周后，尤瑟夫和马纳尔仍在等待。每天晚上，他们都会查看一个名为“拉法口岸”（Land Port Rafah Crossing）的Telegram频道。
Around 10:00 PM, it would post screenshots of a printed list of names. You'd have to zoom in on the photo, and if your name was on that list, you knew to show up at the Rafah crossing the next day. You had been granted permission to cross. 300, sometimes 400, people a day.
大约晚上10点，它会发布一张打印名单的截图。你得放大照片，如果你的名字在名单上，你就知道第二天要去拉法口岸报道。你已经获准过境。每天大约300到400人。
Yousef and Manal's names were never listed. But Yousef started seeing the names of people he knew had registered not long before him showing up on the list. By the end of March, he told me, it must be close.
尤瑟夫和马纳尔的名字从未出现过。但尤瑟夫开始看到一些他认识的人——他们注册的时间比他还晚——的名字出现在名单上。三月底，他告诉我，应该快到了。
How are you feeling?
你感觉如何？
It's happening, and so I feel excited for that.
这件事正在发生，所以我对此感到很兴奋。
You feel excited?
你感到兴奋？
Yeah, yeah, kind of afraid and excited at the same time. So I'm going for nowhere. It's like I'm abandoning a lot of things here in Gaza-- my social status, my value, my job, my career. Ah, so to a new journey, and unfortunately, until now, I don't have any horizon where I'm going, what's the plan.
是的，是的，同时感到害怕和兴奋。我要去一个未知的地方。这就像我在加沙放弃了很多东西——我的社会地位、价值、工作、职业。所以，这是一段新的旅程，不幸的是，直到现在，我还不知道前方有什么、计划是什么。
I'm surprised to hear you say you're excited.
听到你说兴奋我很惊讶。
And excited in a weird way. OK, it's like I want it to happen. And it's like when you are going to get a needle. There is a pain that you go through it, and I just want to do it, hallas.
是以一种奇怪的方式兴奋。好吧，就像我希望这件事发生一样。就像你要去打针。这是一种必须经历的痛苦，我只想赶紧结束它，结束了（hallas）。
Oh, like when you're getting a shot, and you just want it to be over.
哦，就像打针一样，你只希望它赶紧结束。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，正是如此。
So that's not really excited. That's like dread.
那其实并不是兴奋。那是恐惧。
Ah, I don't know. [LAUGHS]
啊，我不知道。[笑声]
[LAUGHS] That sounds more like--
[笑声] 这听起来更像是——
English is not my language.
英语不是我的母语。
[LAUGHS] That sounds more like dread to me than excitement. Nervous. Nervous, maybe.
[笑声] 那对我来说听起来更像是恐惧而不是兴奋。紧张，也许是紧张。
It's kind of, yeah, I just want to do it, hallas. Before that, I did the registration. I was OK with it. I didn't think about it a lot. And but since I registered, it became like a pain that is like, I just want to finish it.
这种感觉就是，是的，我只想赶紧做完它，结束了。在那之前，我做了注册。我觉得还行。没怎么多想。但自从注册后，这就像一种痛苦，我只想把它结束掉。
Mm-hmm, just want to be on the other side already of whatever is going to happen.
嗯哼，只想快点跨过这一关，不管接下来会发生什么。
Exactly.
正是如此。
What is this? This wait to be placed on a list, what is this? And you have to pay to get on the list? Why? There were, at the time, over a million people living in a city that was about to be invaded. There was one way out of Gaza. I wanted to understand what was this opaque process that Yousef was waiting on and could barely talk about.
这究竟是什么？这种在名单上等待的过程，这到底是什么？而且你还得花钱才能上名单？为什么？当时，在一座即将遭到入侵的城市里，居住着一百多万人。这是逃离加沙的唯一通道。我想了解尤瑟夫正在等待的这个不透明的系统到底是什么，以及他为什么几乎无法谈论它。
Chana Joffe-Walt. Coming up, the actual price to get somebody out of Gaza. And yes, they're going to want that in cash. No wire transfer, no credit card, no mobile payment. Good, old-fashioned cash only. That's in a minute, on Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
我是查娜·乔夫-沃尔特。稍后，带你了解让一个人离开加沙的实际代价。是的，他们想要现金。不接受银行转账，不接受信用卡，不接受移动支付。只接受老派的纸质现金。稍后继续，在芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目将继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, we're returning to Yousef Hammash and his family in Rafah, who've been caught up in this war that began October 7 when Hamas crossed into Israel, killed nearly 1,200 Israelis, and took over 240 hostages, and has dragged on for nearly nine months now, over 37,000 Palestinians and over 1,500 Israelis dead and people like Yousef and his sisters trapped in the middle of the fighting.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，我们将回到身处拉法的尤瑟夫·哈马什一家，他们被卷入了这场始于10月7日的战争。当时哈马斯进入以色列，杀害了近1200名以色列人，扣押了240多人作为人质。这场战争已经持续了近九个月，超过37000名巴勒斯坦人和1500多名以色列人死亡，像尤瑟夫和他的姐妹们这样的人被困在战斗的中心。
And back in February, when Yousef decided to try to leave Gaza, leave all this behind, it was hard getting everybody on board, handing off responsibilities. But also it was just literally hard to leave. It was hard to get out.
回到二月份，当尤瑟夫决定尝试离开加沙，把这一切抛在脑后时，要说服所有人同意并移交责任非常困难。而且实际上，想要离开真的很难。
Yousef was cautious when it came to talking about this part of the process, so Chana started asking around. How exactly does it work? How did a person get out of Gaza with the clock ticking? Everybody wondering when and if Israel was really going to do what it had announced it was going to do and actually invade Rafah. What procedure do you go through? Who do you call? What form do you fill out to leave Gaza? Here's Chana.
尤瑟夫在谈论这个过程时很谨慎，所以查娜开始四处打听。这到底是怎么运作的？在时间紧迫的情况下，一个人如何带着全家离开加沙？每个人都在想以色列是否真的会执行其宣布的入侵拉法的计划。你需要经过什么程序？你给谁打电话？填写什么表格才能离开加沙？这里是查娜。
You know it's not a clean, defensible operation when nobody who touches it will talk about it. I spoke with Palestinians who went through the Rafah crossing, or were trying to, people who've reported on the system, people who work inside it. Almost everybody didn't want to talk publicly. They all worried about pissing off the wrong people in the Egyptian military and intelligence.
你知道，当没有参与其中的人愿意谈论它时，这就不是一个清白、站得住脚的操作。我和一些通过拉法口岸离开的人谈过，也和那些试图离开的人、报道过这套系统的人、以及在内部工作的人谈过。几乎没有人愿意公开谈论。他们都担心惹恼埃及军方和情报部门的某些人。
The first detailed document I read about how the Rafah crossing works was an investigation by a group of reporters at a site called the Organized Crime, Corruption, and Reporting Project. And even they, the people who authored the report, did not want to be named.
我读到的第一份关于拉法口岸如何运作的详细文件，是由“有组织犯罪与腐败报道项目”（OCCRP）的一组记者进行的调查。即便如此，那些撰写报告的人也不愿透露姓名。
You can just say that I'm one of the OCCRP reporters who worked on this investigation.
你可以说我是OCCRP参与这项调查的记者之一。
There were several reporters working inside and outside Gaza. I'm going to call this one Naya. Naya explained, after October 7, when Hamas attacked Israel, officially, Palestinians in Gaza with no other passport were not allowed to leave through the Rafah border. Israel closed every other exit point.
有几名记者在加沙内外进行调查。我称这一位为娜雅（Naya）。娜雅解释说，10月7日哈马斯袭击以色列之后，官方层面，没有其他护照的加沙巴勒斯坦人不被允许通过拉法边境离开。以色列关闭了所有其他出口。
But pretty soon, these ads started popping up online, offering to get people out. They were for brokers, people calling themselves travel agents or travel coordinators. Naya pulled up a couple of the ads while we were talking-- travel in luxury, your dignity and pride intact.
但很快，网上开始出现广告，提议带人们出去。他们是中间人，这些人自称为旅行代理人或旅行协调员。我们交谈时，娜雅调出了一些广告——“豪华旅行，尊严与骄傲完好无损”。
And really, I mean, it's like, they're so creepy and tacky at the same time. I mean-- wait. Let me see if I can find it. It was very funny. OK, there's one called the King's Coordinations. It says the strongest coordination on the level of Gaza. And then it says easy and guaranteed. And it has a photo of the Sphinx and then a plane over that Sphinx and then a guy looking very modern, wearing a rucksack on his back and orange jeans. It looks so funny. [LAUGHS]
说真的，太诡异了，同时又很廉价。我的意思是——等等。让我看看能不能找到它。太滑稽了。好吧，有一个叫“国王协调中心”（King's Coordinations）的。它说“加沙最高级别的最强协调”。然后说是“简单且有保障”。上面还有一张狮身人面像的照片，一架飞机从狮身人面像上方飞过，还有一个看起来很时尚的男人，背着背包，穿着橙色牛仔裤。看起来太好笑了。[笑声]
Why is that so funny to you?
为什么那对你来说那么好笑？
Because, I mean, the country is-- I mean, Gaza is a place of death and destruction. And the Sphinx is next to him, and the plane flies over the Sphinx.
因为，我的意思是，这个国家是——加沙是一个充满死亡和破坏的地方。而狮身人面像就在他旁边，飞机飞过狮身人面像。
Mm-hmm, like he's going to see the pyramids with his camera around his neck.
嗯哼，就像他挂着相机要去参观金字塔一样。
It has nothing to do with the reality.
这与现实毫无关联。
Every war has its own manic economy. These travel coordinators were sometimes charging $2,500 per person, sometimes $5,000. It depended who you asked and when. You could send the money from your phone or hand it to a coordinator in Gaza. As best Naya and the other OCCRP reporters could find out, a lot of the money seemed to go to Egyptian intelligence, although Egypt has publicly denied this.
每场战争都有其病态的经济。这些旅行协调员有时每人收取2500美元，有时5000美元。这取决于你问谁以及什么时候问。你可以从手机汇款或直接交给加沙的协调员。据娜雅和其他OCCRP记者了解，大部分钱似乎流向了埃及情报部门，尽管埃及已公开否认这一点。
And the price rose over time. A few months after the war started, we called one of the brokers ourselves and asked what exactly is the price now. And he said, sometimes it's $7,000, $10,000, or $12,000-- $12,000 per person, an astounding number. Before the war started, the average person in Gaza made $3,700 a year. It was very difficult for Palestinians trying to leave to tell who was legit or to price shop. People gave their money to brokers who disappeared. It was the Wild West.
价格随着时间推移而上涨。战争开始几个月后，我们亲自给其中一个中介打电话，询问现在的确切价格。他说，有时是7000美元、10000美元或12000美元——每人12000美元，一个惊人的数字。战争开始前，加沙普通人的年收入仅为3700美元。对于试图离开的巴勒斯坦人来说，很难分辨谁是合法的，也很难去比价。人们把钱给了中介，结果他们消失了。那是荒蛮的西部。
And then, the entire system changed. Egypt controls the Rafah crossing. Here are some things Egypt did not want. Egypt did not want Israel pushing Palestinians from Gaza into Egypt. It didn't want a refugee crisis. It didn't want Hamas getting a foothold in Egypt. Egypt also didn't want to look like it was supporting the displacement of Palestinians by facilitating their exit out of Gaza. And last, Egypt definitely did not want to look like it was collaborating in a black market to charge Palestinians tens of thousands of dollars to save their lives.
然后，整个系统变了。埃及控制着拉法口岸。有些事情埃及不想做。埃及不希望以色列把加沙的巴勒斯坦人推向埃及。它不想要难民危机。它不希望哈马斯在埃及扎根。埃及也不想看起来像是在通过协助巴勒斯坦人离开加沙来支持流离失所。最后，埃及绝对不想看起来像是在参与一个黑市，向巴勒斯坦人收取数万美元来挽救他们的生命。
By the beginning of this year, it did look like that. By February and March, there were reports that the main company offering travel coordination at the Rafah border was making a million dollars a day off Palestinians. The manic economy was reined in. New rules. No more hiring brokers in Gaza to help you register to leave. No more paying by phone. No more free-for-all bribes at the border.
到了今年年初，情况确实看起来是那样。到了二三月，有报道称，在拉法边境提供旅行协调服务的主要公司每天从巴勒斯坦人身上赚取一百万美元。病态的经济受到遏制。有了新规。不再允许在加沙雇用中介帮你注册离开。不再接受电话支付。不再有边境上的随意贿赂。
There would only be one company allowed to register people to leave Gaza, an Egyptian company called Hala with close ties to the Egyptian military and security services. And now, if you wanted to register, you needed to send someone to the Hala offices in Cairo in person. And not just anyone-- a first-degree relative. And you'd need to pay in cash-- $5,000 for an adult, $2,500 for a kid, American dollars only. It's like a dare. How could anyone in Gaza pull this off?
现在只允许一家公司注册离开加沙的人员，那是一家名为“哈拉”（Hala）的埃及公司，与埃及军方和安全部门关系密切。现在，如果你想注册，你需要派人亲自去开罗的哈拉办公室。而且不能随便找人——必须是直系亲属。而且必须用现金支付——成年人5000美元，儿童2500美元，仅限美元。这就像一个挑战。加沙的任何人怎么可能做到这一点？
This new system for getting out of Gaza kicked in just as Israel announced its plans for an offensive in Rafah, just as Manal told Yousef she was ready to leave. A new, much more rigid system that made it much, much harder to get out. Yousef couldn't talk about how he raised that much money, in dollars, and got it to the Hala office in Cairo and how he did it fast enough to register to get on the list in order to maybe make it out in time. Most Palestinians in Gaza didn't want to talk about any of that either. So I reached a Palestinian outside of Gaza on the West Bank.
这套离开加沙的新系统是在以色列宣布其在拉法的进攻计划时生效的，正是在马纳尔告诉尤瑟夫她准备离开的时候。这套新系统变得更加严苛，让离开变得难上加难。尤瑟夫无法谈论他是如何凑到那么多美元现金，并将其送到开罗的哈拉办公室的，也无法说他是如何做到如此迅速注册以便进入名单，从而或许能及时离开的。加沙的大多数巴勒斯坦人也不想谈论任何这些。所以我联系了一位身处约旦河西岸的巴勒斯坦人。
OK, so, first, we set up the GoFundMe page, and that was a whole thing, an ordeal of itself.
好吧，首先，我们创建了GoFundMe筹款页面，那也是一件大事，是一个折磨人的过程。
I knew the system was outrageous, but I didn't know-know until I talked to Bushra. Bushra Khalidi lives in the West Bank in Ramallah. She's Palestinian. Her husband's family is from Gaza, and Bushra wanted to help them get out, seven people, $30,000, which she didn't have and had to fundraise.
我知道这个系统很离谱，但我直到和布什拉（Bushra）谈过才真正了解。布什拉·哈利迪住在约旦河西岸的拉马拉（Ramallah）。她是巴勒斯坦人。她丈夫的家人来自加沙，布什拉想帮他们离开，七个人，30000美元，她没有这笔钱，不得不进行募捐。
So I couldn't say in my GoFundMe page that I lived in Palestine because Palestinians are not allowed to receive any funds from GoFundMe. And they actually emailed me and said, because you're in a risky area, blah, blah, blah, you cannot-- you know. And then I had a co-sponsor with me from the US. Like, eventually, I found somebody. I found a-- it's a long story.
所以我不能在GoFundMe页面上说我住在巴勒斯坦，因为巴勒斯坦人不允许接收GoFundMe的任何资金。他们实际上发邮件给我说，因为你处于高风险地区，巴拉巴拉，你不能——你知道的。后来我在美国找了一个共同赞助人。最终，我找到了一个人……这是一个很长的故事。
Short version-- she needed someone else to help her set up the GoFundMe page. And the way she found that person, her brother-in-law is in a band that tours and knew someone in the US who could help them set up the page. Pretty quickly, talking to Bushra, I got a picture that this is the kind of person you need on your team if your family has any chance of getting out.
简单来说——她需要别人帮她设置GoFundMe页面。她找到那个人的方式是，她的小叔子在一个巡回乐队里，认识一个可以帮忙设置页面的美国人。与布什拉谈话后，我很快就明白，如果你的家人有任何离开的机会，你确实需要这样的人在你的团队里。
Bushra is a lawyer. She speaks perfect English. She works for a global NGO, Oxfam. She's used to navigating bureaucracies in multiple languages. She has connections in countries all over the world. To navigate this complex process, you need someone who can make things happen. You need a Bushra or a Yousef. Apparently, you also need to know someone who's in a band.
布什拉是一名律师。她英语说得很好。她在全球非政府组织“乐施会”（Oxfam）工作。她习惯于用多种语言应对官僚机构。她在世界各地都有人脉。要驾驭这个复杂的过程，你需要一个能让事情发生的人。你需要一个像布什拉或尤瑟夫这样的人。显然，你还需要认识一个玩乐队的人。
So that was the first hurdles. And then it was a hurdle to write the story. Because every time you wrote the story, it has to be verified by GoFundMe, and then they would allow it or not. So they weren't allowing me mentioning that I lived in Palestine, so we had to change the story, but we didn't want to lie. You know what I mean?
这是第一道障碍。然后写故事又是一道障碍。因为每次你写完故事，都必须经过GoFundMe的核实，然后他们才会允许或拒绝。他们不允许我提到我住在巴勒斯坦，所以我们必须修改故事，但我们不想撒谎。你明白我的意思吗？
So we had to then change the story, say that I kind of lived between Europe and Palestine and kind of travel for work. I do travel a lot. It had to be-- we had to write the story in terms of she was fundraising on behalf of me that lived in Europe, who was going to help my family in Gaza.
所以我们必须修改故事，说我大概住在欧洲和巴勒斯坦之间，大概是出差。我的确经常旅行。必须是——我们必须这样写故事：她以我的名义募捐，而我住在欧洲，将帮助我在加沙的家人。
The GoFundMe worked, but it wasn't enough. They raised $20,000. They needed $30,000 for the Hala fees. Bushra and her husband were already sending money constantly into Gaza, money to pay for $200 bags of flour, for transportation every time the family had to move-- five times. Bushra knew if the family made it to Cairo, they wouldn't be allowed to work, so they'd need help paying for housing and food there, too. So actually, Bushra realized, they needed $50,000.
GoFundMe成功了，但还不够。他们筹到了20000美元。他们需要30000美元来支付哈拉的费用。布什拉和她丈夫一直在不断地往加沙汇钱，支付每袋200美元的面粉钱，以及每次家人必须搬迁时的交通费——搬了五次。布什拉知道，如果家人到了开罗，他们将不被允许工作，所以他们在那里还需要帮衬房租和吃饭。所以实际上，布什拉意识到，他们需要50000美元。
So we took a loan out of 20k and then put of our savings, 20k.
所以我们贷了20000美元，然后加上我们积蓄的20000美元。
OK.
好的。
Yeah. All our life savings.
是的。我们毕生的积蓄。
How did you guys make that decision, or was that an obvious choice?
你们是怎么做出那个决定的，还是说这是一个显而易见的选择？
That also was what delayed the process, is like we're currently-- we bought our house a year ago. We're finishing it. So, I mean, it's just been a huge financial strain.
这也延迟了流程，我们实际上——我们一年前买了房子。我们正在装修它。所以，我的意思是，这造成了巨大的财政压力。
I talked to people in Gaza who sold the cars they were living in to pay for these fees. I heard about families that sold their furniture, took out loans, families who hit up aunts and cousins and extended family across multiple countries until every family member's savings was drained. And once you did that, had the money in hand, it wasn't over.
我和加沙的一些人谈过，他们卖掉了赖以生存的汽车来支付这些费用。我听说过那些变卖家当、背负贷款的家庭，还有那些向多个国家的阿姨、表亲和大家庭求助，直到每个家庭成员的积蓄都被掏空的案例。一旦你做到了这一点，手头有了钱，事情还没结束。
The move for us that was really complicated was figuring out a way how to get the money in, because you have to pay cash, in dollars, in Egypt. And in order for you to-- you can't send the money by bank transfer to an Egyptian account. It has to be somebody in Egypt that has a USD account and--
对我们来说，真正复杂的过程是找出如何把钱送进去，因为你必须在埃及用现金支付美元。为了你能——你不能通过银行转账汇到埃及账户。必须是埃及某人拥有美元账户，而且——
Wait, wait, wait, what? So you have to have-- you can't transfer money to an account?
等等，等等，什么？所以你必须有——你不能转账到账户？
No, it's like $40,000 to Egypt.
不，总共有40000美元要汇到埃及。
And you couldn't figure out literally just how to get the cash there?
而你们居然弄不清楚到底该怎么把现金送过去？
How do we get $40,000, 40k in? Well, the thing is, is that I could have flown out and taken it, but then we found out that it has to be a first-degree relative that registers. Do you see what I mean? They have to register the family. And I'm not first-degree. I'm just like the in-law. I'm like the daughter-in-law.
我们该怎么把40000美元送进去？好吧，问题是，我本来可以飞过去带现金，但后来我们发现必须由直系亲属进行注册。你明白我的意思吗？他们必须注册这个家庭。而我不是直系亲属。我只是姻亲。我只是儿媳。
So I couldn't. And then my husband, Palestinian men under 40 years old can't enter Egypt unless you have a specific-- you have to have a permit from the Egyptian authorities and secret services. And they do all the security checks. So that was also not an option for my husband to go.
所以我做不了。我丈夫，40岁以下的巴勒斯坦男性不能进入埃及，除非你有特定的……你必须有埃及当局和特勤局的许可证。他们会做所有的安全检查。所以这对我的丈夫来说也不是一个选择。
Oh my god.
天哪。
So it had to be his sister in Sweden that went out--
所以必须是他在瑞典的姐妹出来——
Just to register them?
仅仅是为了注册他们？
Yeah, so we flew her out and her daughters and her husband, too, because she has two very small kids. So we flew them all out. And their situation is not amazing in Sweden. They couldn't afford $2,500 for the plane ticket. So we paid for those, too. Oh, God. Now I'm talking about-- when I'm counting all of this, I can't believe it.
是的，所以我们把她和她的女儿们，还有她丈夫也飞出来了，因为她有两个很小的孩子。所以我们把他们都飞出来了。他们在瑞典的情况并不好。他们负担不起2500美元的机票。所以我们也支付了机票。天哪。现在我在谈论——当我数着所有这些支出时，简直不敢相信。
Once the sister arrived in Cairo, Bushra then had to figure out how do I get her the cash so she can go in person to register the family at the Hala office. Bushra had a friend in Egypt.
一旦姐妹到达开罗，布什拉就得想办法把现金给她，以便她能亲自去哈拉办公室注册。布什拉在埃及有一个朋友。
He could receive about $20,000 in his account. So I was like, OK, I'll transfer $20,000 to him. And then we sent-- and there was a person-- I'm not exactly sure, and again, I'm not asking questions, but he was like, I don't want to say an agent, but he was like a person that was going to Egypt-- a businessman going to Egypt that was taking money for people, dollars to Egypt for people. So he carried $15,000 for us.
他可以在账户里接收大约20000美元。所以我说，好吧，我把20000美元转给他。然后我们派了——有一个人——我不确定具体情况，再说一次，我没问，但他就像是……我不想说是代理人，但他就像一个要去埃及的人——一个去埃及的商人，他帮人带钱，把美元带给在埃及的人。所以他帮我们带了15000美元。
No way.
没开玩笑吧。
Yeah, basically we paid him $1,500 to take $15,000 with him.
是的，基本上我们付了他1500美元，让他带着15000美元。
And just to be, like, the mule. Just to carry it, basically.
就像骡子一样。只是为了运送，基本上。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, it was risky. That was a risky move.
是的，是的，是的。这是一个冒险的举动。
And did you get the sense that that person is doing that all the time?
你有没有感觉那个人经常干这个？
Yeah, but I don't think it was for necessarily evacuating people from Gaza. It's just he's a businessman. He has businesses in Cairo. So he was able to carry. I don't know. I don't know what he does, but he's like an entrepreneur. I have no details.
是的，但我不认为这必然是为了从加沙撤离人员。他只是个商人。他在开罗有业务。所以他能运送。我不知道。我不知道他做什么，但他像个企业家。我没有细节。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
That, I didn't ask. I was like, cool. We got somebody. My husband didn't really ask. He knew the guy. He knew the guy from a guy. So he was like, OK, cool. He didn't ask questions.
那个我没问。我心想，太好了。我们有人了。我丈夫也没怎么问。他认识那个人。通过熟人认识的。所以他说，好吧，酷。他没多问。
OK, so your sister-in-law arrives in Cairo. She goes to meet your friend who's holding $20,000 for you and the businessman who has personally delivered, for quite a high fee, another $15,000. And all of that, then she collects that, driving around Cairo? Those, like, piles of cash?
好的，所以你的小姑子到了开罗。她去见了为你保管20000美元的朋友，还有那位收取了高额费用亲自送来了另外15000美元的商人。所有这些，然后她就收集起来，在开罗开车到处跑？那些……一堆现金？
Literally.
真的是这样。
Well--
呃——
Yeah, I guess. I mean, is it piles of cash? It's like 350 $100 notes. So it's not--
是的，我想是。我的意思是，那是成堆的现金吗？那是350张100美元的钞票。所以不是——
That's a lot of cash. I mean, it's not a suitcase, I guess.
那也是很多现金。我的意思是，虽然不是一个手提箱。
I guess it is pretty piled--
我想那确实堆得挺高——
But it's not--
但不是——
Yeah, it's not a suitcase.
是的，不是手提箱。
You can't put it in a wallet.
你没法放进钱包里。
No, you can't put it in a wallet. That's a good question. I should ask how she carried it. [LAUGHS] But so they got an apartment right next to the company.
不，你没法放进钱包。这是个好问题。我应该问她是怎么携带的。[笑声] 但他们就在公司旁边租了一间公寓。
The Hala company. The sister-in-law stood in line, paid the money, and then they waited for the names of Bushra's in-laws to show up on the list. Bushra and her family were stuck checking the same strange Telegram channel Yousef was, the one with the screenshots of this life-or-death list.
“哈拉”公司。小姑子排队，交了钱，然后他们就等着布什拉姻亲的名字出现在名单上。布什拉和她的家人被困在和尤瑟夫查看同一个奇怪的Telegram频道，就是那个有生死名单截图的频道。
The wait was excruciating. Bushra didn't want to think or talk about it. Her sister-in-law wanted to talk about it all the time. They were all watching the news and the list. On April 14, their names appeared on the list. The family left the next day.
等待的过程非常痛苦。布什拉不想考虑或谈论它。她的小姑子却一直想谈。他们都在看新闻和名单。4月14日，他们的名字出现在名单上。第二天他们就离开了。
I mean, definitely, when their names came out on the list, it was like a physical-- there was something physical that changed in me.
我的意思是，当他们的名字出现在名单上时，确实有一种身体上的——有一种身体上的东西在我身上改变了。
What did it feel like? What changed?
感觉如何？什么变了？
It just was like-- it's like, OK, they're going to survive. They're going to live.
就是觉得——就像是，好吧，他们会活下来的。他们会活下去的。
Yeah.
是的。
And there's no word for it in English, but maybe you can look it up. In Arabic, it's called Qaher. It's like a mix of anger and disgust-- the word. That's what it means. It's like a mix of anger, disgust, and despair.
在英语里找不到对应的词，也许你可以查查看。在阿拉伯语里，这叫“Qaher”。这是一种愤怒和厌恶的混合情绪。这就是那个词的意思。这是一种愤怒、厌恶和绝望的混合体。
And you felt that--
你感受到了那种——
That's what it is.
就是这样。
--toward what? What made you feel which part?
——针对什么？是什么让你感受到了哪一部分？
I mean, listen. I had never met my in-laws.
我的意思是，听着。我从未见过我的姻亲。
Never met her in-laws because Israeli restrictions make it very hard to travel between the West Bank and Gaza.
因为以色列的限制使约旦河西岸和加沙之间的旅行变得非常困难，所以她从未见过姻亲。
Like, how is it that this has to happen for us to meet and for my son to meet his grandparents for the first time, you know? Like, how? Why? Why do we have to go through this?
我的意思是，为什么非得发生这种情况，我们才能见面，我的儿子才能第一次见到他的祖父母，你知道吗？怎么会这样？为什么？为什么我们非得经历这些？
What is it going to mean to your family to have spent this money on this, like long-term or--
你们全家在这件事上花了这笔钱，从长远来看意味着什么，或者——
Shame. Shame.
羞耻。羞耻。
Shame? Why?
羞耻？为什么？
Because they're ashamed. Because that's not who we are, you know? We've been rendered destitute, you know? They're not destitute people, you know? They had a beautiful home and beautiful lives.
因为他们感到羞耻。因为那不是我们的本性，你知道吗？我们变得一贫如洗，你知道吗？他们不是赤贫的人，你知道吗？他们曾经有过漂亮的房子和美好的生活。
And to put that on your son, I mean, I don't know. I don't know if it's shame, but it's like guilt maybe. It's like they're so grateful that they're ashamed to say it. You know what I mean? It's embarrassing that they put that on us. And so we don't talk about it. It's not like there's a thank you because even a thank you is not enough for them. And so it's better not to say it.
把这个负担压在我的儿子身上，我的意思是，我不知道。我不知道是不是羞耻，但更像是内疚。他们非常感激，以至于羞于说出口。你明白我的意思吗？他们让我们背负这些，这很尴尬。所以我们不谈论它。并不是说连个“谢谢”都没有，因为即使是谢谢对他们来说也不够。所以最好什么都不说。
Do you want to talk about it?
你想谈谈它吗？
Um, no, because I would do it a million times over again. And they know that. I just need to know that they're alive and that they're good. And now, I mean, the thing is, is that they're in Egypt now, and I'm in Egypt now. And but the road ahead is so hard. And coming here and just seeing them, they're not the same people. They never will be the same people, you know?
嗯，不，因为我会再做一百万次同样的事。他们也知道这一点。我只需要知道他们还活着，他们很好。现在，问题是他们已经在埃及了，我也在埃及。但前方的路太艰难了。来到这里看到他们，他们已经不再是以前的人了。他们永远不会再是以前的自己了，你知道吗？
This brings us back to Yousef. Yousef, who knew this, he knew leaving Gaza meant he would not be the same person. And still, Yousef was going through all these steps through a system designed to frustrate, deter, and bankrupt him. Yousef's version of this process, raising an astounding amount of money, getting the cash in dollars physically to the Hala office, Yousef's maneuvers were not the exact same as Bushra's, but they were just as involved and absurd, right up until he was registered and waiting for permission to do something he did not want to do.
这又回到了尤瑟夫身上。尤瑟夫知道这一点，他知道离开加沙意味着他将不再是原来的那个人。然而，尤瑟夫依然走过了所有程序，走过了一套旨在挫败、威慑并让他破产的系统。尤瑟夫处理这个过程的方式——筹集巨额资金、亲自将美元现金送到哈拉办公室——尤瑟夫的做法虽然和布什拉的不完全一样，但同样错综复杂且荒谬，直到他注册完毕，等待许可去完成他其实并不想做的事。
When he was growing up, Yousef's uncle used to tell him he reminded him of his grandfather. He grew up hearing this a lot, the similarities to his grandfather. And Yousef got it. His grandfather hustled, made things happen. He was resourceful. But Yousef has been thinking about this lately, what it meant to be like his grandfather, what else it meant.
尤瑟夫成长过程中，他叔叔常说他很像他的祖父。他从小就经常听到这个，说他和祖父很像。尤瑟夫也理解。他的祖父很努力，能把事情办成。他足智多谋。但尤瑟夫最近一直在思考，像他祖父意味着什么，还有什么别的含义。
His grandfather is the one who got everyone to Jabalia, to the refugee camp in the north of Gaza, when they were all pushed out of their homes in what is now Israel in 1948. His grandfather is the one who made sure everyone got set up in the same place next to each other, made sure they survived, had housing, had their needs met. He made sure they were safe, and they were together. And they were.
他的祖父是那个在1948年他们都被赶出现在的以色列家园时，把大家带到加沙北部贾巴利亚难民营的人。他的祖父是那个确保每个人都住在一起、确保他们幸存下来、有住房、需求得到满足的人。他确保了大家的安全和团聚。他们确实做到了。
Jabalia Camp became a small city. People moved to bigger apartments nearby, had kids, but the family stayed safe and right next to each other. 75 years later, Yousef was the one who moved his sisters and their families to a tent camp in Rafah so they could all be nearby, safe and together.
贾巴利亚难民营变成了一座小城市。人们搬到了附近更大的公寓，有了孩子，但家人始终平安且住在一起。75年后，尤瑟夫是那个把他的姐妹和她们的家庭带到拉法帐篷营地的人，这样他们就能在一起，平安且团聚。
They were there for three months when Yousef heard from a contact in Egypt, a friend with connections at the Hala Company, who told him that his family's names were likely to be listed in the next week. He wasn't just failing at keeping the family together. He was the one who was going to split them up.
他们在那里待了三个月，尤瑟夫从埃及的一位联系人那里得到消息，那是位在哈拉公司有关系的朋友，他告诉尤瑟夫，他家人的名字很可能会在下周出现在名单上。他不只是未能让家人团聚，他竟然是那个要拆散他们的人。
Yousef, are you packing?
尤瑟夫，你在打包吗？
I don't have anything to back. That's the easiest thing about it.
我没什么好包的。这是最简单的事情。
That's the easiest part? [LAUGHS]
那是最简单的一部分？[笑声]
[LAUGHS] I have two jeans pants, two T-shirts, two jackets, and actually, most of it, I will leave it for my brothers-in-law. I'm just going to take just what I could wear during the first day and just a pajama for the next day. And that's it. The easiest part is packing. [LAUGHS]
[笑声] 我有两条牛仔裤，两件T恤，两件夹克，实际上，大部分东西我会留给我姐夫。我只带上第一天能穿的，再加一件换洗的睡衣。就这样。打包是最简单的。[笑声]
What's the hardest part?
最难的部分是什么？
[SIGHS] It's also packing. [LAUGHS] Tangibly, there is nothing to be packed during the journey, but we are packing our relations with our families now. I don't know how it's going to be that day when we are just going out. And I don't want to really think about that moment because I don't know how it's going to be. And, yeah. Yeah, it's going to be difficult. I don't want to think about it. Let's wait and see.
[叹气] 也是打包。[笑声] 从有形上看，旅途中没什么可打包的，但我们现在正在打包我们与家人的关系。我不知道我们要离开的那一天会是什么样子。我真的不想去想那一刻，因为我不知道会怎么样。是的。是的，这会很困难。我不想去想它。让我们走着瞧吧。
[PHONE RINGS]
[电话铃声]
Hi, Yousef.
嗨，尤瑟夫。
Hello, Chana.
你好，查娜。
Hi.
嗨。
Hi. How's your day been?
嗨。你今天过得怎么样？
Yeah, I don't know. It was a bit long and [SIGHS] yaani, end up with our name listed by the Egyptians to cross tomorrow to leave to Egypt.
是的，我不知道。这天过得有点长，[叹气] 结局就是埃及人列出了我们的名字，允许我们明天过境去埃及。
Wow.
哇。
And I wasn't expecting that soon, but looking to my sisters. Today, I received the news when I was with my sisters. And it was really difficult, how to deal with it.
我没料到这么快，但看着我的姐妹们。今天，我和姐妹们在一起时收到了这个消息。这真的很难，不知道该怎么应对。
You were with your sisters when you found out?
你收到消息时和你的姐妹们在一起？
And they were list-- 'cause they list the names usually after 10:00 PM in the night. So we were there, having iftar with Aseel and the rest of my sisters, Heba and Hadil.
她们通常在晚上10点以后列出名字。所以我们当时在那里，和阿西尔还有我其他的姐妹，赫芭（Heba）和哈迪尔，一起吃开斋饭。
I have a friend who lives in Egypt. And he have some access with the Hala company, which is the company that we registered through it to cross to Egypt. And he told me that my name is not listed. It's not going to be listed today, so I don't need to wait for the list. It's going to be listed for tomorrow.
我有一个住埃及的朋友。他有渠道接触到哈拉公司，就是我们注册过境的那家公司。他告诉我，我的名字没在名单上。今天不会上名单，所以我不需要等名单了。应该是明天。
So I decided we were having iftar with my sisters. I told them that we are leaving the day after. And I just wanted to use that day with them. We agreed to have iftar together, all of us. And we were planning for tomorrow that even I don't want to go to work. I want to spend it with my sisters. I take my family there. We spend the entire day there.
所以我决定……我们当时正和姐妹们开斋。我告诉她们我们后天就要走了。我只想利用那一天和她们在一起。我们商定大家一起开斋。我们计划明天甚至不去工作。我想和我的姐妹们在一起。我把家人带到那里。我们在那里待了一整天。
Then we go back to prepare ourself to travel. And suddenly, when we were there, one of-- it's the wife of one of our colleagues who lives with us. She called and she said, your names are listed. And it was very shocking, and suddenly, everything became a chaos. Everyone started crying. And it was a very emotional moment that I didn't want to see.
然后我们回去准备出发。突然，当我们还在那里时，我们的一位同事的妻子，她和我们住在一起，她打来电话说，你们的名字上名单了。这太令人震惊了，突然间，一切都陷入了混乱。每个人都开始哭泣。那是一个非常情绪化的时刻，我不想看到。
My daughter Illya was crying because her aunts are crying, my wife is crying, my mother is crying. [SIGHS] And then I found myself in this chaotic situation, trying to understand if it's the right option or not, if it's--
我的女儿伊利亚在哭，因为她的阿姨在哭，我的妻子在哭，我的母亲在哭。[叹气] 然后我发现自己陷入了这种混乱的境地，试图弄明白这到底是不是正确的选择，如果它——
You were having doubts?
你有疑问吗？
Yeah, yeah, of course. I am going for nowhere, leaving behind me everything. An entire life. And this is the second time I'm leaving things behind. I left my house in the north toward the south. I left my house, my memories, everything in the north.
是的，是的，当然。我要去一个未知的地方，把一切抛在身后。一整个人生。这是我第二次把东西抛在身后。我从北部的家搬向南部。我离开了我的家、我的回忆，北部的一切。
Now I'm trying to understand or to imagine how my sisters are feeling when they are losing their backup, their support. Whenever they want anything, whenever they are facing anything, they know that Yousef is there.
现在我试图理解或想象我的姐妹们在失去依靠、失去支持时是什么感觉。无论她们想要什么，无论她们面临什么，她们都知道尤瑟夫在那里。
What did they say, Yousef? What did they say to you?
她们说了什么，尤瑟夫？她们对你说了什么？
Everyone was in a shock, including me. Everyone was crying, and I was looking to my sisters. I felt how weak I am to make that decision. I don't have enough courage to leave everything behind. And this is one of the hardest moments in my life.
每个人都震惊了，包括我。每个人都在哭，我看着我的姐妹们。我感到做出那个决定我是多么软弱。我没有足够的勇气把一切抛在身后。这是我一生中最困难的时刻之一。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, it is [INAUDIBLE]. When I was looking for my sisters, when they are thinking about losing their entire family, it's not only me. It's my wife, my children, their mother. I couldn't find the right word. What should I say?
是的，这是。[听不清] 当我看着我的姐妹们，想到她们要失去整个家庭，不仅是我，还有我的妻子、我的孩子、她们的母亲。我找不到合适的词。我该说什么？
And the issue is that I was very overwhelmed emotionally. And if I said-- and it happened. When I start to talk to them, I was trying to show how strong I am. And I was like, it's fine. Since a month I informed you to be prepared for this moment. Then here where I lost control of my emotions.
问题是我的情绪完全崩溃了。如果我说——它就这样发生了。当我开始和她们说话时，我试图表现得坚强。我说，没事的。一个月前我就通知你们要为这一刻做好准备了。然后，就在这里，我失去了对情绪的控制。
It's usually I'm that tough man who cannot be seen as a weak person. And I understood how weak I am. And I don't want to be shown weak in front of them, but it's out of my hand. My sisters, I think they-- I believe they know. They know that I will do anything for them and whenever they need anything. I already prepared everything. And--
通常我是那个不能表现得软弱的硬汉。我理解自己是多么软弱。我不想在她们面前表现得软弱，但我控制不住。我的姐妹们，我想她们……我相信她们知道。她们知道我会为她们做任何事，无论何时她们需要什么。我已经准备好了一切。而且——
Yousef, you told me over the last months that every time I asked how you feel about leaving, you were sort of like, I can't. I don't know. I'll know when it happens. I don't know. I can't think about it. Do you feel like you're suddenly thinking about it now?
尤瑟夫，过去几个月你告诉我，每次我问你对离开有什么感觉时，你总是说，我不能。我不知道。等到了那一天我自然会知道。我不知道。我不能想它。你现在突然觉得自己在想它了吗？
I was postponing thinking about it because I understood how hard it is. And I was doing right. I was doing right today when I received the news and then knowing that I'm leaving tomorrow. I never felt the pain inside me like today. And I was right. I was right. And now it's real. It's happening. And I'm leaving Gaza tomorrow. It's like losing my identity.
我一直在推迟思考它，因为我明白这有多难。我这样做是对的。我今天收到消息知道明天要离开时，我确实做到了。我从未像今天这样感到内心的痛苦。我是对的。我是对的。现在一切成真了。它正在发生。我明天就要离开加沙了。这就像失去了我的身份。
When are you leaving?
你什么时候走？
I'm leaving 7:00 AM in the morning.
我明天早上7点出发。
Oh, wow. You're leaving in six hours.
哦，哇。六个小时后你就要走了。
Yeah, I'm leaving.
是的，我要走了。
Are you going to sleep?
你能睡着吗？
I don't know if I could manage to sleep. Because tomorrow morning, at 7:00 AM, I have to go to meet my sisters again before we leave. And I want to make sure, even if I have one more minute to spend it with them, I'll do it. I don't know. Chana, I'm going through one of the most difficult-- it's not one of the most. It's the most difficult decision I've made in my entire life.
我不知道能不能睡着。因为明天早上7点，在我离开前我必须再去见我的姐妹们。即使还有一分钟的时间可以和她们在一起，我也会去做。我不知道。查娜，我正在经历我一生中最困难的——不，不是之一。这是我一生中做过的最困难的决定。
I know.
我知道。
And now I'm just leaving everything. Now I am leaving. And they will be refugee once again. Born as a refugee, raised as a refugee, and now starting a new life as a refugee.
现在我把一切都留下了。现在我要走了。她们将再次成为难民。生为难民，长为难民，现在又开始了作为难民的新生活。
Yousef, I want to let you go have time with your family and also hopefully sleep some before you have to make that trip tomorrow.
尤瑟夫，我想让你有时间和家人在一起，也希望你在明天出发前能睡一会儿。
Thanks. Thank you, Chana. Thank you so much. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you. And I think our next call will be from a different place.
谢谢。谢谢你，查娜。非常感谢。是的。谢谢。谢谢。我想我们的下一次通话将会在不同的地方。
Yeah.
是的。
Hopefully it will go OK.
希望一切顺利。
All right. Bye, Yousef.
好的，再见，尤瑟夫。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
再见。再见。
Bye.
再见。
Yousef left through the Rafah crossing the next day. That day, his family saw the world outside Gaza for the first time. The kids were amazed by the electricity in Cairo and the trees. Trees in Gaza have been cut down now to use for fire. When Illya and Ahmed started to tell their cousins in Gaza about the watermelon they were eating and the playground they played on, Yousef had to tell them to keep that kind of thing to themselves from now on.
尤瑟夫第二天穿过了拉法口岸。那天，他的家人第一次看到了加沙以外的世界。孩子们对开罗的电力和树木感到惊奇。加沙的树木现在都已被砍伐用作柴火。当伊利亚和艾哈迈德开始向加沙的表亲们讲述他们吃的西瓜和玩的游乐场时，尤瑟夫不得不告诉他们，从今往后要把这些事藏在心里。
Manal took the children to the market and bought chocolate. Yousef sat at the computer, continuing to try to make plans for his sisters, trying to figure out where were the Israeli tanks now, what might their approach into Rafah be, what was the intensity of the bombing that day, and what did it mean. Were the NGOs leaving Rafah yet? Were other people leaving? Was it time for his sisters to move somewhere else in Gaza?
马纳尔带孩子们去市场买了巧克力。尤瑟夫坐在电脑前，继续努力为他的姐妹们做计划，试图弄清楚以色列坦克现在在哪儿，他们对拉法的进攻可能是什么方式，那天的轰炸强度如何，这意味着什么。非政府组织离开拉法了吗？其他人也离开了吗？是时候让他的姐妹们转移到加沙其他地方了吗？
Then, on May 6, the Israeli military sent tanks into Rafah. The invasion had finally started. That same day, there was news that Hamas had agreed to a ceasefire. It was very confusing, but for a couple hours, it seemed like maybe there was going to be a ceasefire.
然后，在5月6日，以色列军队将坦克开进了拉法。入侵终于开始了。同一天，有消息称哈马斯同意了停火。情况非常混乱，但有那么几个小时，似乎好像真的要停火了。
I was very, very excited and hyped. And it was like, what to do? It's like, OK. Yaani, start to think about what next, what I'm going to do with the family. It's like, ah, I should go back to Gaza. And then I start even to look at what is the process to go back to Gaza as soon as I can. And--
我非常、非常兴奋和激动。心想该怎么办？就像，好吧。就是说，开始思考下一步，我该怎么安排家人。我想，啊，我应该回到加沙。甚至我开始研究我能以多快速度回到加沙。然后——
What? Really?
什么？真的吗？
It might take one, two weeks. Yeah. I'm useless here. What am I doing here? Watching the news? Writing reports? I want to be there. The only option for me is to go back to Gaza. And even with my sisters, I can just drop them in the car, and we keep running in Gaza from a place to the other. I don't mind it.
可能需要一两周。是的。我在这里没用。我在这里做什么？看新闻？写报告？我想去那里。对我来说唯一的选择就是回到加沙。即使和我的姐妹们在一起，我也可以把她们接上车，我们继续在加沙从一个地方跑到另一个地方。我不介意。
Yousef was suddenly back to the person I remembered talking to for every other move before this last one-- energized, frantic.
尤瑟夫突然又变回了我在之前每一次搬迁前认识的那个尤瑟夫——精力充沛、近乎疯狂。
I start to think rationally about what I'm going to happen, what I'm going to do. And the plan that I'm having now is to figure out a way how to come back.
我开始理性地思考接下来会发生什么，我该做什么。我现在拥有的计划是找出回去的方法。
But that day, there was no ceasefire. And the next day, the Israeli military seized the Rafah crossing into Egypt and closed the border. There was no way back. Yousef would be in one world. His sisters would be back home in another.
但那一天，并没有停火。第二天，以色列军队占领了通往埃及的拉法口岸并关闭了边境。没有退路了。尤瑟夫将身处一个世界。他的姐妹们将回到家园，身处另一个世界。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our show. Chana's story about Yousef was edited by Laura Starecheski and Nancy Updike. Our episode today was produced by Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who put together today's episode include Jendayi Bonds, Zoe Chace, Michael Comite, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Safiyah Riddle, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特是我们节目的制片人之一。关于尤瑟夫的故事由劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基（Laura Starecheski）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）编辑。今天的一集由阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）制作。参与今天制作的人员包括詹达伊·邦兹（Jendayi Bonds）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、迈克尔·科米特（Michael Comite）、伊曼纽尔·佐齐（Emmanuel Dzotsi）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、娜迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、萨菲娅·里德尔（Safiyah Riddle）、瑞安·鲁梅里（Ryan Rumery）、弗朗西丝·斯旺森（Frances Swanson）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Reporting, research, and Arabic translation from Hany Hawasly. Arabic interpreting from Emna Zghal and Sawsan Abdelatif. Arabic voiceover by Leem Lubany. Additional reporting by Fatma and by Dana Ballout.
我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的资深编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的总编辑是埃曼纽尔·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。报道、研究和阿拉伯语翻译来自哈尼·哈瓦斯利（Hany Hawasly）。阿拉伯语口译来自埃姆娜·兹加尔（Emna Zghal）和索桑·阿卜杜勒拉蒂夫（Sawsan Abdelatif）。阿拉伯语配音来自利姆·卢巴尼（Leem Lubany）。额外报道由法特玛（Fatma）和达娜·巴鲁特（Dana Ballout）提供。
Special thanks to all the reporters at Mada Masr and the Organized Crime, Corruption, and Reporting Project. Thanks also to Shaina Low, Mona Chalabi, Miriam Marmur, Tara Abboud, Adam Bakri, and Rania Mustafa. Casting help from Sabrina Hyman.
特别感谢Mada Masr的所有记者以及“有组织犯罪与腐败报道项目”。还要感谢谢娜·洛（Shaina Low）、莫娜·查拉比（Mona Chalabi）、米里亚姆·马默（Miriam Marmur）、塔拉·阿布德（Tara Abboud）、亚当·巴克里（Adam Bakri）和拉尼亚·穆斯塔法（Rania Mustafa）。选角帮助来自萨布丽娜·海曼（Sabrina Hyman）。
Our website, if you're going on a long drive, going on a vacation, looking for something to listen to, over 800 episodes of our program streaming for absolutely free. ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He keeps getting pulled into these spats on X, especially with this one guy. Torey couldn't remember his name, Elon something.
我们的网站，如果你正在进行长途驾驶，去度假，想听点什么，我们节目有超过800集内容完全免费在线流媒体播放。ThisAmericanLife.org。本节目由公共广播交流中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他总是被卷入X平台上的这些争吵中，尤其是和那个家伙。托里记不起他的名字了，叫伊隆（Elon）什么来着。
I don't know what he does, but he's, like, an entrepreneur.
我不知道他做什么，但他像个企业家。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。